today I had a report by the United
Nations saying you know the spread of
Islamic extremism across the world and
especially the countries that seem you
know so many people of different
nationalities seems to be going to the
Islamic state or al-qaeda that is on the
rise and there's this helplessness and
we've tried military means we're still
trying them we've tried
counter-surveillance means and those
means they answer certain problems but
there's no ideological confrontation I
don't think that the answer lies in some
top-down solution I think the answer
lies in figuring out who are the people
who are most who will most benefit from
a change and what is it that they will
you know what are the tools how could we
reveal these tools of manipulation to
them and how can we get them best to
unite within this mass of humanity who
subscribed to Islam there's something
simmering there are changes people are
being pinched in many different ways if
you are a woman you were sexually
harassed you're subjected to honor
killings you're subjected to a forced
Merritt is suffering your children are
denied education if you're a little boy
you're subjected to a whole host of
cruelties you probably take an advantage
of sexually abused all of this all of
this going people are thinking that
getting together and the means are there
the internet if you can read and write
but before the internet it was audio and
radio and video and all that if you look
at a mass of one-fifth of humanity 1.5
1.6 billion people and you think I'm
going to look for some leader up there
who's going to manipulate them all like
puppets which is what we've been doing
the last what how many hundred years and
we are now coming to the conclusion
work that way but at the same time we
find ourselves through technology that
there is a bottom-up variant
do you remember Occupy Wall Street it
came out of nothing the Ferguson
Baltimore demonstrations all of us as
far as we know it was a bottom-up event
something bad happens and then poop the
masses are out there demanding the heads
but there's something simmering in